j'ai besoin de prendre un bloc de terre
et et partir dans l'inconnu
je me laisse guider je sais pas du tout
du tout où je vais et c'est la terre qui
me donne le mouvement qui me guide
anne boisaubert et me dire qu'elle est
tombée dans la terre c'était il ya
quelques années comme un coup de foudre
elle prend alors des cours de céramique
puis de sculpture depuis elle ne cesse
de créer c'est toujours des sentiments
des instants de vie donc je passe je
passe dans ce que vit l'humain j'étais
souvent des blancs le plus pur au noir
le plus simple c'est à dire vraiment des
sentiments des sentiments très doux la
rêverie l'amour la douceur et jusqu'à
jusqu'à des choses plus forte plus la
douleur la mort pour peaufiner la
sculpture une fois que j'aurai vraiment
décider de ce que je veux faire
soit je prendrai des photos
soit j'aurai besoin d'un modèle qui va
poser dans cette position pour vraiment
reprendre au plus juste m'approcher de
la vérité du corps est parti tu la
verras plus jamais doucement thema elles
vont venir étreindre son corps le
chercher et le vouloir l'enveloppé de m
contre toi tu peux aussi fermé les yeux
pour mieux imaginer
es tu là comme s'ils étaient contre toi
ce jour là pascal le modèle doit trouver
la bonne position pour exprimer le
sentiment que chercher ils m'offrent les
lignes par exemple à de la douleur donc
avec les muscles tendus avec ses mains
qui cherchent eux l'être aimé avec et du
coup bien sûr ça moi la terre je la
place et et je retrouve
je retrouve ce sentiment le partage en
fait on est on est dans la même histoire
[Musique]
de cet étonnant dialogue entre la terre
et ses doigts naissent des terres cuites
des résines des bronzes
voici sa dernière création requiem de
loire j'ai voulu rendre un hommage aux
morts et aux disparus de la loire voilà
vous voyez ici tous les corps d'hommes
de femmes d'enfants entre mêlée qui
composent sa chevelure
[Musique]
j'ai créé ce beau visage parce qu'elle
reste c'est un beau fleuve j'ai je les
admire mais elle est dangereuse c'est
très très doux j'ai voulu faire ça comme
un ballet flottant
[Musique]
les sculptures d'un oiseau vert dégagent
les émotions les forces et les failles
des coffres l'humain est sa principale
source d'inspiration
[Musique]